they calculated like in terms of
happiness if you can help people achieve
a fairly modest reduction in their trait
neuroticism then in terms of happiness
it's equivalent of an increase in your
income to over 300 000 a year if you can
achieve these real genuine shifts and
some of your trait scores it's going to
make a difference to your life
the topic that i know you came to talk
about is
post ejaculatory adaptations to
self-semen displacement a study that i
recently read
and i've found in this contrary to the
prevailing view male sexual jealousy
accounts for more cases of family
violence eg spouse and child abuse than
social class poverty alcohol or drug
addiction combined this was shared by
rob henderson the other day
high level what are your what are your
thoughts on post ejaculatory adaptations
to self semen displacement
wowzers
that's yeah that's the most uh
left-field question i've had uh i would
say
um
oh yeah well you know men are like yeah
jealousy probably accounts for a lot of
um
bad personality change
absolutely well i think as well like one
of the things that men are pretty hard
wired to avoid is being cooked right you
know to raise somebody else's child so i
guess that
the jealousy must be tuned up a little
bit more
in that regard for men
yeah i mean more seriously i guess there
is an evolutionary thread that runs
through you know a lot of the
personality research and um
these kind of you know you get their sec
important sex differences in personality
and that kind of thing you know to do
with the
average gender differences in some of
the traits and yeah the kind of thing
you're talking about you know
aggressiveness and competitiveness and
and so on so
it does tie in and it uh loosely in in
some ways we've looped it back around
all right so what do you mean when you
talk about personality
well
the way i uh approach it is the
the way it it is covered in personality
uh in in psychological science by
personality researchers so that like the
formal
approach which is so personality is our
it's a combination of our habits of
thought
uh feeling the way we relate to other
people
and you can measure these
these tendencies with the big five model
of personality so that that's kind of
that basically that's what i mean by it
in this book that i wrote
um i took the scientific route you know
there are other models like the
myers-briggs that kind of thing there
are some of these and even more you know
wackier ones than that that are less
scientific
but what i mean by is those
ingrained behavioral tendencies and um
like a favorite way that personality
researchers have of describing it is
that
you can tell what's your personality
because it's how you behave without
putting any effort into it you know so
if an extrovert a strong extrovert walks
into a room
uh
they don't think to themselves right i
better make an effort to start chatting
to the people in the room that kind of
thing it's it's it's just how they act
because it's how they are
how
woo
or unscientific
are most of the other personality
measures and other elements if big five
is what personality is then what's
attachment theory or what's
myers-briggs or that
red blue
green thing
uh yeah they're pretty woo because i
mean um
they don't have that uh scientific
robustness so the the problem with them
is i mean on the plus side a lot of them
are very popular engaging they're fun so
you're getting people thinking about
personality they're thinking about their
behavior and how they relate to other
people that kind of thing so that's on
the plus side the problem with a lot of
these other approaches is
uh you do the test one day and do it
again the next day and you get a
different score that you know that kind
of thing you know so they just don't
hold up too much scrutiny that's part of
the problem
what's the difference between
personality and mood then
so mood is it's over the short term so
your you know a
mood state is a it's a state so it's a
transient uh condition
personality very much that's probably
something i should have said in the
definition is something that very much
plays out over the long term
so we all have our moments where we're
lazy
no matter how kind of conscientious we
are you know we'll all have lazy moments
no matter how uh highly we score in
agreeableness you know we're all gonna
have we're all gonna have our grumpy
days and not be short-tempered so
everyone
everyone has these little fluctuations
but the key thing with personality is
if you keep doing the measures over the
long term you see these tendencies and
their meaningful tendencies you know
as we really know you know intuitively
we know that we know that our you know
we've got some friends who are chattier
than others or we've got some friends
who are
uh you know um
more idle or whatever it might be
so uh personality is like mood smeared
across time then
exactly and it i mean i do think the
this is something i explore around the
book is
these uh sort of short-term influences
interact with our personality so that
there is this kind of malleability to
personality and of course the little
these little influences day by day can
accrue they can accumulate and i do
think they're important you know
it's worth paying attention to them
uh because uh obviously is the case i
make is that personality isn't set in
stone so um
it can slowly shift you know like a like
an oil tanker it can be gradually
shifted but
uh yeah these the momentary changes are
yeah things like moods or emotional
state that kind of thing
how much does personality matter for the
outcomes that we get in life
i would say absolutely hugely
um i mean it personality traits these
big five traits correlate with all sorts
of important outcomes you know
whether it's longevity
career success
uh relationship success or versus
difficulties
your health
so many different that your physical and
mental health it
and they often many studies will show
that the the big five trait scores
are as influential
as or even more influential than other
things that people might think of such
as family background economic background
uh amount of education yeah that that
kind of thing so they're
they are
it's hugely important there was one
study one of my favorites
that was focused on trait neuroticism
and it that they
um
they calculated like in terms of
happiness if you can help people achieve
a fairly
modest
reduction in their trait neuroticism
then in terms of happiness it's
equivalent of of an increase in your
income to
over three hundred thousand dollars a
year so
just to get some kind of handle on
if you can achieve these real genuine
shifts and some of your trait scores
uh
it's going to make a difference to your
life
and probably a little bit easier than
trying to earn an extra 300 000
a year absolutely yeah okay so
getting down to a
biological or a
neuroscientific level what's what's
personality there is is it just
like myelin sheaths running through the
brain what's going on
yeah because it can see it seems
sometimes a little bit i suppose willy
and subjective
you know
but um again these these big five traits
they correlate with them uh
significantly with some very meaningful
uh physiological parameters suggesting
that
um
personality the
one way of putting is that it gets under
the skin so
for example people hire in neuroticism
which basically means you're
less emotionally stable and less
emotionally resilient
they have less folding in their brain
less surface area in parts of the brain
that are involved in emotion regulation
for example
you find that people who score
higher in conscientiousness you know how
self-disciplined they are orderly
ambitious
that kind of thing they have um
i mean one study looked at levels of
cortisol in the hair like because you
can measure cortisol in the hair people
who score higher on a personality
test in conscientiousness they have
lower cortisol in their hair and
cortisol is a
hormone related to stress and
inflammation and that kind of thing
so
these kind of more objective
measures um the gut microbiome is
another one that correlates with um
some of these
big five traits you know whether you
have kind of uh
healthy more healthy gut bacteria or
less healthy
blood pressure heart rate you know quite
a lot of these things they correlate
with these big five traits suggesting
you know there is like this objective
component to it um so it's not just
uh
learned
behaviors
it's not just habits and routines people
have predispositions
um physiologically
that are gearing them toward being a
particular style but i imagine that
there must be multiple different ways to
achieve certain personality types so
somebody could be a high neuroticism
because of that folding
element or maybe they have uh more
cortisol receptors perhaps uh maybe that
there's a ton of different ways that
could be contributed to that
biologically then it could be learned
behavior maybe it was past trauma maybe
it's to do with attachment maybe it's to
do with upbringing maybe it's to do with
whatever so it's kind of the same way as
i had robert plowman on the show and he
was talking about the uh heritability of
weight and he was saying that he
naturally gets quite fat but mentioned
that there's lots of different ways to
be fat you could be fat because your
ghrelin response is down regulated so
you don't actually know when you're full
and satiated that well maybe you have an
aversion to exercise maybe you require
more sleep than most people so you're
more sedentary maybe
like the point being that you can reach
the same state
uh in terms of presentation as other
people
whilst coming to it from a very
different place is that right to say or
wrong
yeah absolutely so there is a there's a
strong genetic component to our
personality traits you know which
tapping into some of those biological
processes you know that you you were
mentioning
uh but it's about 50 it counts for about
50 percent of the very variation that
you see in personality between people so
you've got that leaves obviously a large
chunk
shaping us
for uh
our experiences our relationships
the environment that we're raised in and
all these things and continues these
factors continue to play a role through
life
and those
fi you know sort of physiological
parameters that i mentioned that are
connected to the traits i think you have
a fee you know you've got you've got a
two-way
feedback loop so
if you're in poor health or if you don't
if you don't pay attention to you know
your fit physical fitness and so on
there are studies suggesting that is
going to have a harmful influence on
your personality traits how
so things like lack of sleep
um smoking
these kind of things are correlated with
uh
you know longitudinal studies show
further down the line you see these kind
of harmful effects on the trait
on personality traits what which traits
in particular europism
uh
numericism
particularly um
conscientiousness
open-mindedness you know
uh they will suffer
um
extroversion as well with with uh
smoking extroversion will tend to go
down because it affects uh
habits like smoking affect our ability
to enjoy reward you know other forms of
reward
so you
these um
behaviors or you know things like our
diet our sleep habits our fitness
uh routine you know habits lifestyle
like i guess you might say
they uh
affect some of the you know our
underlying physiology that is relevant
to personality traits yes and it's this
constant feedback
yeah exactly yeah i mean that's part of
what i you know the message i try and
convey in the book is sort of trying to
hack
some of these feedback loops
um
that exists in our between personality
and biologic biological uh
processes and and the kind of lives we
lead you know kind of trying to hack
into the the these dynamics these
circles
there's a
guy from stamford's andrew huberman had
him on the show a couple of months ago
and he was talking about how he prefers
to try and change the mind with the body
rather than with the mind and i think
that that kind of gets to this um
physiological interdependence between
the way that you feel the things that
you think the habits you have the
routines that you follow the way that
you show up what you do with your body
and all of these things are loops and
this is as well
peterson was on the show at the start of
this year and he was talking about um
how
people accuse
pareto principal distributions of of um
well-being or wealth or whatever
they sort of point the finger at
capitalism and say look at these evil
capitalists doing this and he says well
almost all of the rivers have almost all
of the water almost all of the stars
have almost all of the mass like these
kind of matthew principles just play out
like this is just the way that it
happens and you can see it happening
here as well if somebody starts smoking
that means that it's going to be more
difficult for them to do this and that
and the other and it just
helps to continue to push them down and
the reverse is true as well and you see
these trajectories of people just start
to split apart because the person that
has good habits engenders more good
habits which gives them better results
which reinforces the good habits
all the way up
yeah exactly it's it's
a lot of i think
exploiting the research into personality
change is recognizing that certain
things in motion in the right direction
and stopping them
spiraling downwards
um yeah you you might be aware of you
know these kind of studies they came out
of um
dunedin in
new zealand these very long term studies
where they actually looked at kids
uh temperament you know from a very
young age and yeah chilled children you
know with lower self control
which is related to when we're adults
related to trait conscientiousness
you know the kids with lower self
control they are far more likely to grow
up to be the adults
who are gonna you know gonna be
unemployed gonna have poor health and so
on and so forth
so that
uh i know the you know one criticism is
that that is pinning the blame on the
individual rather than um acknowledging
circumstances but it is also empowering
because
these things aren't set in stone so you
know
it opens the door to an early
intervention and it opens the door to us
taking control of some of these
factors ourselves by deliberately
changing ourselves
thinking more consciously and
deliberately about you know what we do
with our lives and where we put
ourselves the
situations we put ourselves in as well
didn't you look at another study that
the longest longitudinal personality
study ever done where people were rated
by teachers in school and then were
tested again at 70. and that showed that
there was a lot of change between the
personalities so what does it mean to
talk about personality at all like
doesn't that kind of undo
what we just said about the fact that
people that don't have so much
self-control later in life like if the
if the personality isn't consistent
throughout life then why would anything
in early life be predictive of stuff
later in life
yeah one thing to say about that study
that was a scottish study and i think it
was the longest ever was it it was
focused on one sort of tiny part of
personality when it was related to
conscientiousness but i mean it had a
number of um flaws that study so i i did
highlight it because of the dramatic
finding that there wasn't a correlation
between
the scores in childhood
and the scores in like you say they were
about 70 something
um but i mean there were a few flaws so
the the the childhood ratings were done
by teachers i think
and uh whereas when they were in their
70s they like rated themselves and and
stuff but
um
i mean what
what the experts usually say is
the like the rank order
uh so like
you know if you were towards
the quieter end in your class in your
group when you're at school you'll
probably although you will all um
shift through life because there are
these kind of maturity effects through
life
um
you'll probably still be you know
towards the lower end uh even if your
whole class has shifted on like
extroversion you'll probably still be in
the sort of the same rough roughly the
same rank
um
there was another recent study i think
it looked over 50 years um comparing
personality uh
scores with the same group of people you
know with it with a 50-year gap
and
they looked at 10 different traits you
know rather than just the sort of the
one and i think they
they found 98 of the uh participants
showed meaningful change on at least one
of the the 10 traits
um
so they were
of so that obviously there there were
some other traits you know that shows
some stability it's this mixture of um
and i i tried to deal with this in the
book like trying to you know get across
it's not it's not set in stone but it's
uh it's relatively stable
but there is some change as well so it
is meaningful personality is meaningful
while not being totally fixed yeah so
the best
analogy and there's lots of similarities
i think between personality and what i
learned about behavioral genetics just
because there's that kind of set point
and
an amount of
um existing
direction and then also the stuff and
the change that you can make with
regards to environment or personal
choice and uh ploman says um genetics do
not predetermine but they do predispose
yeah and i feel like that
highlights the personality thing all
right so
is it right to say that who we are
is our personalities and if that's the
case
what does it mean to change the
personality
does that mean that we're like not
accepting ourselves does that mean that
we're changing who we are the the
existential gap between
chris's personality and chris himself
yeah so it can start to get quite
philosophical
yeah about like what makes us us
and um
i wanted to yeah i mean i i delved into
this stuff because i wanted to know how
much we can really change for the better
you know i'd been covering psychology
and neuroscience for so many years
writing about cool new studies and so on
i this was something i kind of kept
coming back to like does any of this
stuff really work long term
and i suppose that's personality
provided i thought provided an excellent
frame for that because it's kind of
getting down you know really deep down
it's not just changing habits it's not
just changing your routines it's really
these are your as we were just
discussing you know relatively
long-lasting
uh stable traits can we change those
um
so it is it's a very important part of
who we are it's one way of capturing
what makes us us i wouldn't say it is
everything um
other things you know that are important
part of who we are are things like our
our morals
uh our values you know um
in some ways i would say our
relationship you know the the
relationships that we hold there that
are meaningful to us that is a key part
of who we are so we can change our
personality but still love and care
about the same people you know we can
change our personality but still have
the same
core values still believe in the same
priorities and principles in life
um
other aspects of ourself you know that i
i encountered you know
uh researching this stuff was you know
like all the stories the story we tell
about our lives in in a way is a part of
who we are and of course it can be told
different
you can tell your own story in different
ways and that is that
you've probably heard there's a form of
therapy and like narrative therapy and a
lot of that is about helping people
tell their story differently and that
and thereby actually in a way change
themselves or how they
what they feel like you know to
themselves
um
so yeah i it isn't every for these
personality traits aren't everything
they're very very important part of who
we are but they're not not everything i
suppose the interesting thing about
personality is it's so in its
inextricable
from the way that we present for pretty
much everything else so our
relationships and the story that we tell
ourselves and the
values and virtues and integrity that we
hold are all influencing and being
influenced by the
natural set point that we have like our
predisposition what is it that we are
tending toward so i guess it seems it
seems to me the way that i'm kind of
framing it is it's like
the foundation or the source code or the
the set point the beginning that
everything is coming off of is our
personality and then what you want to
try and do is be swimming downstream you
want to try and get yourself to a stage
where your personality makes having the
kind of life that you want to have more
easy as opposed to you being some
incredibly unconscientious person that
has dreams and goals and aspirations to
go and make something better of yourself
and you go well hang on a second i have
this desire and yet something in me
isn't allowing me to manifest that
desire like that that sucks so
it's got to be a case that it is again
like this completely interdependent
um link between the two
it definitely is because
you know if
you know like if any of your listeners
for example you know frustrated in their
careers or something like that you know
they're finding it really hard to get
motivated
obviously one thing they can do is start
to try and
uh
enhance their trait conscientiousness
their various ways of doing that that's
something they can do you know they can
work on themselves from the inside out
try and change that key personality
trait
but it's very important to recognize
that
actually when people find themselves in
a job or
find a passion that really um
uh
you know sets them on fire really you
know uh
satisfies them um
it feeds back and increases trade
conscientiousness you know it's much
easier to be conscientious if you're in
a job that you're enjoying that you care
about
so
you're absolutely right it's this
interdependence again yeah
i was a club promoter for most of my 20s
and was pretty obsessed with work and
and trying to gain success and also just
grow the business because it was
something that i felt like i had a lot
of um
personal investment in like
my sense of self-worth and the self the
success of the business were kind of
pretty closely linked and i remember
thinking i got to the end of my 20s and
i started learning about leverage which
is this concept whereby you can use
capital labor code or media in order to
magnify your effects out into the world
and i wasn't doing that i was running
club nights right there was no leverage
there really it's like look for one
person that came in one person came in
it wasn't that i ran the club knight
once and then could run it like
uh command c command v and then it would
just run for the rest of time we always
had to be there blah blah blah so it was
low levels of leverage and i was
learning about leverage at a time when
my uh motivation was waning a little bit
within the business and i remember
thinking oh [ __ ] like i've
i've spent the fuel that i had of that
kind of obsessive passion that super
conscientious grind and drive
and i've spent it on something which i
really really value and i love what i
achieved with the business but there
wasn't a massive amount of leverage
there so
maybe i've missed out on the opportunity
to maximize this particular part of the
drive that was in me
and then whatever four or five years
hence now doing the show
and because i get such positive feedback
and the dopamine from the show is just
insane i've now rediscovered that same
degree of drive and conscientiousness
and obsession that has been fed back to
me by another new project but this time
it's with leverage
and it's
i remember thinking it was just an
interesting insight that i've not spoken
about before that i thought i'd
not wasted because i didn't waste it all
and i adore the work that i did and it
was very successful and fulfilled me
but i was concerned that i'd kind of
spent all of the the fuel tank that was
there and i saw in front of my own eyes
what happens when the environment
re-enables and like re-kick-starts that
capacity for
super super super high conscientiousness
yeah so i think in an alternative
reality
version of reality if you hadn't made
that
big career change
i think what the research would predict
is um
there is a risk
like you say you you had a lot of
motivation you were very organized and
driven
but
obviously something was
uh
the reward was diminishing maybe or
whatever as you were describing if you
hadn't made that
i guess ambitious shift there's a risk
you could you might have seen
uh
your conscientiousness
your po it might have started to
adversely affect your personality
basically basically is what i'm saying
yeah yeah
what does it mean to say adversely
affect our personality is that are there
preferable personality states that
people should want to be in
yeah i mean it's a little bit uh
tactless to use that kind of like
language
but um
it's hard to dispute some of these links
between something like conscientious
because higher conscientiousness is
associated with so many preferable
outcomes in life so it's a little bit
whilst not wanting to be judgmental of
people who are low in the trait you know
it's it's hard it would be hard to
advocate for
lower conscientiousness
because um you know you're likely to
have worse health worse
career prospects
there you can go too far with
conscientiousness you know it can
potentially slip into sort of obsessive
unhealthy perfectionist tendencies
but um
exactly what you're describing is these
you know these roads that we travel down
all these situations we find ourselves
in their life
they are all the time you know kind of
feeding back and shaping us
and yeah being aware of
these influences and um i think one of
the techniques i describe in the book
it's
it's from um the personality
psychologist brian little
and he he calls it um personal project
analysis i think that's what he calls it
and it's all about actually taking the
time sit down reflect on all the you
know the various personal projects you
have from
the really big ones like running uh you
know a nightclub
um
to more trivial things about maybe being
on a diet or whatever it might be like
going through them all
checking out you know like am i making
progress on this particular personal
project
is it making me feel happy what kind of
effect is it
having on me
uh and being a little bit brutal and
looking through and saying should i drop
some of these personal projects because
they're
they're
they're not making my life any better so
i should drop them pivot try something
else
and um
sounds like that's what you did
have you considered why
having
different personality types amongst
humans would be adaptive on a tribal
ancestral civilizational level
oh yeah there's there's quite a lot of
you know research on that kind of thing
uh because there's you know animals have
personalities as well so there's a lot
of um
there's actually quite a lot of
personality research with animals and
you can see
basically
you know like we we were saying about
the set point that we kind of our via
our genetic inheritance and so on that
we begin with
our personality disposition if you like
that we start out with is a little bit
like our own
niche or our own kind of strategy
so
while
um
there are a lot of advantages for
example to being more extroverted
extroverts tend to be bolder
uh you know they're more likely to get
the uh on the hunt you know they're more
likely to get the lion's share of the
hunt the kill
um
they're more likely to uh
you know find a mate uh
to reproduce with that kind of thing
there's there's also a niche and
adaptive advance advantage niche for the
person who is a little bit uh more
cautious who hangs back who looks out
for danger uh
so
it for a lot of these things there's
usually
um
you can see some pros and cons depending
on where you kind of
where you sit on the continuum with some
of these traits and
even if for the majority of people it's
better to be one way
you can sometimes see oh there's
um you know there's an advantage over
here for a minority of people who might
be
uh
different you know whether it's being a
little bit more wary or whatever it
might be yeah especially across
an entire group size of a tribe or
something i'm gonna guess as well you
know if you've got i learned this about
uh psychopaths i asked about how
psychopathy uh sticks about i was like
look if you've got a dunbar number of
100 or 150 or something why they're not
all just killed like and if there's a
strong genetic component to this why
they're not all just killed and the guy
that i was speaking to said well
kind of but also if you're a viking
tribe and you want to send a raiding
party across to linda's farm for them to
go and [ __ ] up some geordies
in whatever
uh 100 bc or 100 a.d
it makes sense to have some psychopaths
so it's actually adaptive and i guess
it's kind of the same here that if
everybody was super conscientious and
super extroverted and super whatever
whatever what we would consider to be
more preferable states no one's actually
going to be saying hang on do we
actually think that this is a good idea
maybe we should sit back maybe we should
consider this that and the other uh and
yeah across an entire population it does
make sense and then also our desires
around other people you know i i
am more attracted to
friends that are
a little bit more um introverted than a
super extrovert like i i find it
exhausting to be around people that are
incredibly extroverted all of the time
i'm much more comfortable around people
that are a little bit calmer a little
bit more peaceful so
that there you go that immediately if
i'm the demand and they're the supply
like there is a demand supply problem
for me to find someone that's a little
bit less extroverted
yeah yeah absolutely and
you could even take a trait like
maybe that isn't you know so obvious
because not so much to do like fighting
and aggression and boldness and uh
something like um openness to experience
that which is one of the big five
so people who are you know more open to
experience they are um you know they
don't like
sticking to convention
and rules
they like doing things different you
know being more um
yeah
yeah yeah exactly so yeah so yeah on a
political front you know uh
conservatives tend to score
lower in openness to experience but as
you were saying like on a kind of tribal
level
it's good to have a mixture because if
everybody's caught highly in openness to
experience which comes with many
advantages openness to experience you
know it's related to creativity
among other things
uh but if everybody was high and
openness to experience you would you
know you wouldn't
you wouldn't have anyone following the
rules
yeah there'd be no order you wouldn't
have anyone passing down the
tribal conventions and the higher
respecting the hierarchy and that kind
of thing so as you say there's
balance on a group level it makes sense
yeah
we've used the word extraversion a bunch
of times because that's one of the
elements within the big five but that's
not the same as being extroverted or
introverted
can we just unpack that and how
introversion and extroversion kind of
manifest within personality because i
think for a lot of people when we talk
about personality one of the things that
they might be
interested in is how do i become uh less
anxious or more outgoing or more
socially confident stuff like that
especially in
2022 yeah um
so uh
in in the big five trait theory it's
it's extra it's trait extroversion
basically and it's a continuum so we're
all on it somewhere we will score
somewhere on extroversion
the
talking about introverts and extroverts
is kind of not so scientific in a way
it's uh because you know where where is
the cutoff point is the short it's a
shorthand for
uh in personality science a kind of
shorthand for someone who scores highly
on extroversion and an introvert someone
you know scores towards them sorry i
thought
is extroversion not to do with uh like
valence to positive experience or
something like that
that's right uh that's a that's an
important difference from how we use the
term and kind of colloquially
um because yeah colloquially we tend to
think it's just about being chatty and
and that kind of thing but um
yeah importantly in in scientific terms
extroverts one key thing about
extroverts is that they're very much
driven to achieve reward that they
they're very much drawn to reward their
and positive emotion so they seek out
um positive emotion it's probably one of
the reasons why they are more socially
active because they're looking for that
uh
the reward of that social kick you know
and um
they tend to be more optimistic
extrovert so uh you know if you're a
high score scorer on extroversion um
tend to be more optimistic more active
extroverts are actually more active
they're more like um
exploratory in a way seeking out reward
looking for that reward introverts are
less
responsive to positive rewards they're
less
seeking stimulation it's like their
baseline levels of arousal uh they're
happy with
uh their chill seekers you know rather
thrill seekers
that's interesting i like that
distinction
um
what about what so we've spoken about
the fact that we can change personality
what are the
stickiest
bits of personality what are the things
that the most difficult to change
well um
i would say it so it's all quite
different i wouldn't i don't think any
personality change is really easy
because
as i was saying earlier it's more than
just
tweaking you know
quitting some bad habits and forming
some new ones to achieve lasting
personality change
i mean personality is sticky so you've
um
you've really got to go you know
invest for the long haul you've got to
do things you've got to make changes and
start behaving differently
and there are various ways to you know
to to do that
we might want to cover um
you've got to you've got to practice
these techniques and strategies and make
these changes in your life at a pretty
rigorous and radical level really
um
in terms of like what's i mean
probably i'm guessing i don't actually
know if some traits are harder than
others but i'm get i'm guessing
neuroticism
as in uh yes like as i'm saying that
emotional instability
is probably the one people struggle with
the most and i only say that because
when people are asked what part of the
personality they would most like to
change that is the most popular
change that comes up in surveys
people wish they were not so
emotionally unstable they they crave
uh emotional stability and
uh contentment i guess yeah well i mean
it makes sense that in a self-report the
things that people struggle to change
the most would be the things that would
come up first yeah and i also guess that
there's maybe a kind of like a
self-defeating element
to
neuroticism the fact that
having a high susceptibility to negative
emotion
would make
downstream from that a lot of the
changes that you're trying to enact more
difficult
so it's kind of
one of the matthew principle problems
that we mentioned earlier on
yeah i mean speaking from experience i
would say yeah i i personally
personally i would say i find dealing
with
changing narcissism the hardest and
something for people to be mindful of if
they kind of embark on trying to change
some of their traits is watching out for
interactions because i think i
i think i've i found it like but you
know when i was writing the book
as you can imagine i tried to live out
some of the
advice so as you should do i guess you
know practice as you preach and i think
things like uh conscientiousness
there are so many prac you know sort of
practical steps you can take things you
can do
um
extroversion as well uh by i actually i
think you can get some interactions if
you're not careful because if you start
getting if you've got some neurotic
tendencies
uh you know um
you can start to get stressed out about
you know some of your things you're
trying to work on in other aspects of
your personality so
it's uh worth sort of watching out for
all the the the dynamics between the
different aspects of yourself and the
different traits very interesting what
about uh the roles that we play in life
and how they interact with our
personality like if
we get a new job or we join the army or
we become a parent or something like
that you see people they talk about i'm
such a different person since
x y z i got married i had a kid i
started this new job what's going on
there
yeah well exactly it's one of the you
know
these big life changes
have yeah a huge influence on
personality so um one of the most i
think robust theories is uh social
investment theory this is this idea of
you know that when we take on roles that
are
meaningful to us that we find rewarding
and they're very clearly signposts to us
what is required of us that's a very
important part of it you know where it's
very made very clear to you this is what
is required of you and you get a
feedback loop because you get rewarded
for when you fulfill those
requirements
um then you you see people increase in
trade conscientiousness and that's
called social investment uh theory
and uh yeah some of the other things you
mentioned um
yeah becoming a parent some of the
findings here are
kind of a little bit confusing because
you might think
of all the roles in the world becoming
apparent might increase people's
conscientiousness but they the studies i
found did not uh that that wasn't the
result they got and the research has
speculated that that is because you know
what i was saying about it it being
necessary that it's very clear what is
required of you
the researchers in this case speculated
that becoming apparent isn't linked with
becoming more conscientious partly
because it's just such a maelstrom of
chaos when you become apparent is that
it's actually not that clear what's
required of you it can be pretty
overwhelming so actually you tend to see
uh at least in the very short term you
know you will tend to see increases in
neuroticism
self-esteem might go down
surprisingly and this is short-term and
um
extroversion can go down as well again
not that surprising because you you know
it's much harder to socialize and get
out and about that kind of thing um
but yeah now relationships is not
another one you know getting married you
tend to see so you know people's again
extroversion goes down
[Music]
after getting married
um
that kind of thing and
just friendships and
and so on can influence us because um
i think what you know just now you're
describing about the kind of people you
like hanging out with because of how
they make you feel there's this really
cool concept which is pretty new there
isn't a lot of research on it
called affective presence and it's this
idea that it's almost like another
trait if you like that we so we each
have a certain affective presence which
is how we tend to make other people feel
um
so if you yeah if you spend your time
let's say you got a new job and your
colleague who you work with every day
is particularly grouchy bad tempered and
boring or whatever it might be that is
uh so they got very negative effective
presence and it brings up you know you
imagine you're in that job for months or
maybe years
every day you're exposed to that
influence it's worth being mindful of
these things and how they actually yeah
it's going to shape your own personality
i can see how this would be adaptive
again as well if you get into a
relationship or if you have a kid being
higher in neuroticism being more attuned
to negative emotions makes sense because
that will probably tune you into the
negative emotions perhaps of the newborn
child or your partner that you just got
into a relationship with reducing
extroversion
is going to mean that you're less
outgoing you're less sort of seeking
which is also going to be protective of
you and a family i'm going to guess
maybe getting into a relationship might
reduce openness to experience a little
bit as well although conversely maybe
you could say well now i have somebody
comfortable that can back me up which
means i can afford to be more open i
don't know my point being that like i
can see an adaptive explanation for a
bunch of these different things um you
talk about a challenge mindset and a
threat mindset as well what's that and
how does that play a role here
oh yeah well i i think i brought that up
in the book in relation to because i
have this chapter on um the dark triad
you know you i know you mentioned
psychopaths earlier let's get into it i
want to talk about you you want people
to to channel their inner dark triad and
utilize it talk talk to me about that
and then yeah without relate to the
challenge mindset
yeah without fully going over to the
dark side yes but still the advantages
without yeah the negatives that's what i
was trying to uh
find ways to do that and yet um so
something that psychopaths
uh have have you had kevin dutton on
your show i have not i
had oh his name's going to escape me not
keith campbell keith campbell was the
guy that did narcissism yeah uh
matt williams michael williams someone
like that so he i haven't had kevin
dutton on do you think i should bring
him on is he cool
he's very cool yeah
and i'll get an intro to you uh to him
after once we're finished yeah he he
wrote the wisdom of psychopaths
and uh yeah so one of the sub traits so
there are these kind of three sub traits
in psychopathy and one of them is what
they call fearless dominance
so you you don't want the other two um
the impulsivity
and the emotional coldness you don't
know
but the fearless dominance
can be very uh advantageous and it could
explain why some people who score highly
in psychopathy
uh find themselves in successful careers
like becoming ceos
surgeons special forces
that kind of thing because they got the
fearless dominance which isn't in a way
is like very extreme extroversion like
off the scale extroversion and off this
off the scale low
neuroticism you know they don't feel uh
i think kevin ductin says it's like
they've got ice running through their
veins kind of uh situation
so yeah i'm thinking would it be pretty
cool to have um
more fearless dominance i'd like some of
that and uh yeah one suggestion i had in
the book is looking into this um
line of research
which i think kind of comes from sports
psychology which is the yeah as you said
the kind of threat mindset challenge
mindset so
try to get out of the threat mindset
when you're faced with a daunting
challenge to be more like a psycho a
successful psychopath
try to get out of the threat mindset
because the threat mindset is about fear
of failure
it's thinking you don't have
the skills to deal with this
challenge
um it that kind of thing it's seeing it
you know it's it yeah as i say it's it's
worrying about the failure and the
embarrassment that will come
and
loss of reputation and that kind of
thing
challenge mindset instead of seeing it
as a threat see it as a challenge see it
as something you can learn from
remind yourself
of uh the skills that you have that are
relevant the effort you know the work
you've put
in in the past that shows you can do
this kind of thing
focus on what you can control because
the with the threat mindset you're
worried about you know what if this goes
wrong what that goes wrong i can't
control it with the challenge mindset
you you focus you deliberately focus on
those things that you can control
um
and
and see it as a learning process as well
see it as a learning don't say it as a
like uh some kind of litmus test
am i
worthy or am i
you know a successful person or am i not
don't say it like that see it as a
learning experience what can i take from
this if it goes badly well
i will learn from that and it won't go
so badly next time
dude i love it i absolutely love that
that's something that i've relied on an
awful lot over the last um two years or
so as like the show's grown pretty
quickly and i've had to get myself
continuously into rooms with people
where i go i there is no reason that i
should be here and yeah trying to
reframe things as you know it's either
you either win or learn uh look at all
of the relevant experience that i've got
this is an opportunity this is not
something that i should be concerned
about i can control the controllables i
can't control the uncontrollable so i'll
let those go you know all of that piled
together so it's nice to see that my bro
science solution to
not shooting myself on a podcast has
been borne out in the literature as well
um
i had a guy called vincent haranam on
the show he writes for colette um data
scientist but just fascinating guy his
insight into human nature is fun
brilliant then he came up with the dark
gentleman so he was talking about this
specifically with regards to dating but
he was trying to find a way to turn the
dark triad traits into a
um parental investment protected
provider
but still keeping some of those elements
in there as well so i think what a lot
of people are doing basically is
trying to find some of the value that we
can see
in
the positive elements of either
psychopathy
dark triad traits
and then trying to ameliorate those so
that you don't go
you know like full and rotate and go
completely off the deep end with stuff
um
getting into some of the advice that
you've got obviously we've spoken about
personality we've explained the fact
that it is something which is a
predisposition that doesn't necessarily
predetermine
what what's the fundamental
understanding that people need to have
when it comes to actually changing their
personality what are the the most
important principles that people need to
keep in mind uh here is the thing i
heard that christian guy he said that i
can make some changes to my personality
what are the principles that people need
to keep in mind whilst going through
this journey
i would i'd probably say the most
important thing and i i guess i've
hinted at this already is um
if you really genuinely want to change
you've got to be willing to shake things
up
if you if you carry on doing everything
the same if you stay in the same
relationship you stay in the same job
live on the same street hang out with
the same buddies
if you don't make any like if you don't
check things up at all it's very very
unlikely you're going to change very
much because we are sensitive to these
external forces
so i think you've got to ask yourself
how
far are you willing to go
so if you're not wanting to go very far
you need to be realistic about the
amount of change
you're going to be able to achieve
so being realistic is another important
thing if you are if you really really
want to you know
change yourself
take your life in a new direction
be radical about what you're willing uh
the steps you're willing to go to
um some other things to bear in mind are
you you're gonna need help from other
people probably it's gonna be very hard
i would think it's probably going to be
very hard to do as an entirely solo
project
it's going to help if the people close
to you are on board
as well um
partly because of these uh you know
social dynamics that we were talking
about if your
closest partner let's say also aspires
to similar
uh personality traits and aspirations as
you
um
that's going to help a lot no because
they will role model some of the the
change you're trying to achieve they
will positively reinforce when you make
the changes in the direction that you
care about
so that that's that's another very
important uh factor
i would say
it's an ongoing project it's not
something that's done one you know a job
done one day
and i i'm really conscious of that
myself i think you know
it's just we never know what life's
gonna throw at us next do we so um
it's a constant unfolding pro i i i
think the way i put it in the book is
it's like a philosophy to live by
recognizing that we're a kind of work in
progress
so don't just think you know you're
gonna do a few little psychological
tricks and
uh make a few steps and it's all going
to be job done it's it's more about
recognizing
the malleability of your underlying
traits
recognizing that they're always prone to
change and you've got to keep working at
it you've got to be the kind of best
version of yourself you've got to keep
working at it
um maybe just the final thing is
again i think it goes back to something
we mentioned earlier is um
although it
it's a good case for working on some of
your of your personality traits to help
you achieve what you want in life
i think the research on balance says
more often personality change happens
the other way around it's more often
that we're shaped
by our goals and values in life so think
hard about you know who do you want to
be what kind of person do you want to be
what do you want to do with your life
because once you set on
you know that particular course
that's going to shape you a lot so it's
worth
it really is worth
reflecting on that you know and and the
path you want to take
and um
because that is going to feed back and
actually influence your personality and
the kind of person you are
that's interesting so think about the
sort of person that you want to be over
the long term
design a life that would engender that
type of person to come out of you
be around people that would encourage
that person have pursuits that would
encourage that person to have a job live
in a place be with a partner so on and
so forth i think um one of the things to
pick out there that's really important
is the long-term
perspective
so
i'm 34 right and
i still believe that the thing i'm doing
now or
the habit that i'm working on now or
whatever is just it's going to be that
for the rest of time my ability to do
like my hyperbolic discounting is just
completely [ __ ] right
it's just i'm none of it and
my ability to be able to look at stuff
over a long term really really really
sucks but the difference the advantage
of doing that
is that when you have setbacks because
setbacks are going to come with whatever
whether it be personality change or just
starting a gym routine or whatever
change it is that you're trying to do in
life
there's going to be a period where you
reset back to where you are now and it's
going to make you feel like you're back
at step zero but you haven't accounted
for all of the good work you've done up
until that point and it is very much a
case of
like trading a stock right it goes up
like yes sometimes there's pullbacks but
what is the trend over a long term and
this is something only really probably
within the last year that i've been able
to look at
correctly myself and go
the number of blips
for uh low mood for not hitting
discipline for not doing the things that
i know make my life good have become
increasingly infrequent
and the consistency of me doing the
other things but it felt like i was
on this same path for
four or five years
before i got to the stage where i could
actually reflect and see
genuine tangible consistent change
and i think well no surprise i was
feeling demotivated
four years ago because i was doing
the thing i wanted the thing and this is
the expectation that you were talking
about before it's like okay what is it
that you want to get out of life what
are you prepared to sacrifice if there
is too much of a delta between those two
things you're permanently going to feel
dissatisfied because you're always going
to want 10 and be prepared to sacrifice
enough to get four
and the six is always going to hurt and
on top of that as well i think to add in
think about the fact that 10 is going to
take a lot longer to get to than six or
four are going to get to so okay maybe
you are here maybe that means there's
going to be more blips there's going to
be more resets and over time the goal is
to be at 10 in 10 years not to expect
that you're going to be at 10 within six
months
yeah absolutely yeah
there are no quick fixes
so um
meaningful change is going to take a lot
of effort
um it's also
the sort of thing you're talking about i
think is another one the principles i i
finish up with in the final chapter
which is about
making sure you kind of um
monitor your progress don't just assume
the things that you're doing are working
and it's all going to be hunky-dory
uh so what your those periods of
reflection that you've had and kind of
looking back over that longer time span
i think is very important because
just because something sounds like it
ought to be working it sounds like a
positive step it might not be um
and
another thing is it it might work for a
while and then stop working
you know uh so what you know a very
important i think psychological
attribute is um
psychological flexibility you know it's
being
being adaptive changing
using different strategies mental
strategies and cognitive strategies and
emotional strategies
according to the circumstances and
according to how you change you know as
you get older and your circumstances
change
um
it it's a trait that psychologists are
particularly you know it's not one of
the big five the psychological
flexibility but it's a very popular area
of research
and actually a very very recent study um
you know was looking at people people's
ability to reach their goals
and it one of the you know they would
they would this study was trying to look
at like which strategies are the most
effective you know is there is there one
that's better than others that kind of
thing they didn't find that one
strategy like kind of willpower strategy
was better than another for achieving
goals what they found was most important
was having lots of different strategies
that was the thing so you can switch
things up find what works you know
depending on
the context and so on
talk to me then let's get specific
one of the things that most people are
going to probably want is to be less
idle and be more ambitious basically
increase trait conscientiousness what's
a way that someone could do that
um
one of my favorite kind of findings here
is
that it's not so much about having uh
iron willpower you know when
when researchers compare people who have
high trade conscientiousness with those
with low
um they've kind of done these studies
you know where they ping them on their
smartphones to find out what they're
doing at different times of day
were they exerting willpower were they
resisting temptation what were they
doing you know what's the difference
between these people who have this
amazing conscientiousness and these
people who are less self-disciplined and
the thing is with the people who um have
high conscientiousness is they they seem
to avoid temptation in the first place
it's not that they're
it's not that they have ironclad
willpower
they seem to be
quite strategic in the way they live
their lives so they don't expose
themselves to the environment design and
the people that you're around and stuff
like that
yeah i mean they don't necessarily do it
consciously
someone who is high in conscientiousness
they don't necessarily it's not because
they've yeah like read a magazine
article on how to
uh yeah like design the kitchen to put
the cookies up the top or something but
but maybe we if it doesn't come
naturally to us maybe we can reverse
engineer that yeah exactly yeah
so that's one thing um
there are others i don't know how many
keep going keep going man people wanted
people want to be more ambitious
yeah um
i think there's another interesting line
of research again to do with willpower
which i mean willpower i think is very
relevant to conscientiousness because
conscientiousness is you know it's about
being more orderly and self-disciplined
um
so
there's there are these findings to do
with willpower that actually people who
see willpower as um
kind of re uh like the more that you
expend it it's kind of uh
self-perpetuating like a dynamo on a
bike kind of uh scenario like the the
more hard work you do the more energized
you become
people who see
think about willpower and think about
effort in those kind of terms
uh they seem to have more well they have
more willpower they get less drained by
uh exerting self-control people who
think of willpower as you know you've
got a little bit in your in your tank
and you know i've been working hard
today uh
um ego depletion is setting in yeah
exactly i've been on the spreadsheets
all day so i'm well i'm i'm not going to
have any
self-control left so i better go down
the pub and um it's all it's
self-perpetuating so
it's worth thinking about your mind you
know mindset so i i suppose um dude have
you considered i i learned about that
maybe
three years ago something like that that
basically your view on willpower
determines your experience of willpower
that yeah willpower depletion and the
roy baumeister marshmallowy stuff
is is basically a self-fulfilling
prophecy what do you believe about
willpower ends up enacting that um i
learned about that a while ago and i i
wonder how many people in the world or
how many man hours or productivity or
happiness has been gotten rid of
because of that self-fulfilling prophecy
you know what i mean
yeah yeah yeah i think there's a
definitely a danger of that one one of
the studies that's come out recently
that challenged that i don't know if you
came across this one where they they
tried to find evidence of ego depletion
cross-culturally and it didn't they came
out with null results in india
and then they're trying to they tried to
find out well why why can't we get the
ego to pollution in in india and then
they reflected on the fact that in their
cult in indian culture from a very young
age
uh children are taught about how
energizing it is to be to do
self-disciplined activities and they're
encouraged you know much more than in
the west
uh you know to do sort of concentration
based activities like reading and and
things like this i think they they even
have this kind of
i can remember what it's called but this
kind of meditative type
exercise they do to do staring at a
candle or something from a young age so
they're the various kind of uh these are
bloody conscientious indians
yeah i uh dude i i think that that's one
of and it ties in perfectly with our
mutual friend david robson's work the
expectation effect right like this is
the expectation effect in
action this is it happening in front of
our faces so
if all that anybody takes away from this
episode is
my view on willpower determines my
experience of it if i believe myself to
gain more willpower by using more
willpower that is how it will show up
and this literally is borne out in the
studies you
you get to choose and here again the
matthew principle coming in or whatever
you want to say like that separation the
people that believe willpower is
depletio depletive will have
significantly worse results than the
people that don't and over time that
means that their results are going to
continue to diverge so i think that's a
really a cool insight what about
um
emotional stability then what about if
someone wants to become more emotionally
stable like everyone
yeah yeah um
oh there are so many different so it
when it comes to this one
we can borrow from techniques that are
used in psychotherapy
um that's one thing we can do so you
know cbt
uh that kind of thing so you can you can
use cognitive reappraisal so
um
i suppose this overlaps a little bit
with something we mentioned earlier but
you know when you're when you're feeling
your heart racing before a scary uh
activity before a date or something and
you know you're sweating and your
heart's racing
uh into learn to interpret it as uh
excitement rather than fear for example
that's just one i mean
there's something called affective
labeling which is when we're feeling
these negative emotions like anger
jealousy
most of us are not naturally inclined to
be very good at
identifying these emotions like putting
a label specifying it so take a moment
paul when you're feeling these negative
emotions pause
think to yourself actually say it out
loud well what is it what is that
emotion that i'm feeling
it's called this is called affective
labeling and researchers have found that
this uh
dampens down the negative emotions and
they they think it's because
by taking that moment to pause and
identify it and think of
think about the
you know a granular level what is the
emotion i'm feeling it it draws our
attention to the precursor you know what
led me to feel this way we're more
likely to
act upon it in a constructive way
um
it creates distance as well right you
know you're distancing yourself my
friend corey allen meditation teacher
calls it the mindfulness gap isn't it
fascinating that um
cbt has come up with uh what was what
was that one something labeling
affective labeling effective labeling
but if you were doing the passenger
meditation it would be noting right yeah
yeah you know and it's different
perspectives
on different sort of terminology but on
the same sort of element okay so we have
the ability for people to um refrain
stuff as i'm not nervous i'm excited my
friend bridget says that before she goes
on stage she's a comedian who started
late and she has a little mantra i'm not
nervous i'm excited i'm not nervous i'm
excited uh the um
labeling
uh what else give us a final one when it
comes to uh psychological stability and
mood and stuff
okay we'll find one a little bit
different and maybe maybe slightly less
obvious is um
i don't know if you you know these kind
of uh brain training like tasks
so there's one there's one called the
n-back task so if any of your listeners
google n-back task
the letter n-b-a-c-h
b a c k
so n n hyphen b a c k yep
yeah the n back task um
google that there are loads of free
versions online it's to do with keeping
track of a train of numbers or letters
and every now and again you're prompted
to recall
the lateral number that was n
numbers back in the sequence there's a
kind of form of cognitive kind of brain
training that
uh trains your you know your cognitive
ability to kind of pay attention because
you can have two dual streams so you get
good at kind of monitoring two at once
this these exercises have been shown to
reduce anxiety
and researchers think that's because one
cause of anxiety is a lack of
mental control over our thoughts you
know we find our
mind drifting to worry some worrisome
thoughts
uh brain training exercises like the in
back task give us
help us
cultivate more mental control so it's
another way of getting a grip over your
sort of emotional regulation
that's cool as like adding in some extra
ram okay so final one i think look at me
just uh claiming to know what everybody
wants from their personality improvement
um i think that
becoming more confident and more
extroverted is probably something else
that a big chunk of people would like
have you got any advice or any
techniques that you like to improve that
um
yeah there's what so
extroverts tend to be more um optimistic
you know when they
live longer as well
uh they have better health i think
there's some confusing research around
the yeah generally i think they have
better health so they tend to live
longer for that reason but they are also
more prone to kind of um
risk-taking behavior like jumping off a
building or something yeah exactly so
yeah you get that
yeah yeah
yeah um
anyway they tend to be more optimistic
so
that's one reason they're more willing
to throw themselves into these uh
challenging social situations and other
things
there's uh there's a whole that there's
a range of interventions for increasing
optimism and one of them is called the
best self
uh
best self exercise or something like
that um
it it it all it really involves spending
some time sitting down and you can
repeat this you know each day to get
into the habit of it and imagine
picturing yourself kind of five years or
so hence
everything's gone uh as you hoped or
your or your dreams have come true
uh this kind of thing and it's so it's
it's spending some i suppose you can see
it as like a little meditation exercise
spending some time imagining oh best
possible self that's what it's called
best possible self again if you google
it i think it comes up um
so yeah prep
studies have shown that regularly
practicing this little exercise helps
increase um
optimism and that's going to feed into
your extroversion
i mean i would say with trait
extroversion
more than any of the other of the big
five traits
it's
uh
it's kind of um it's the fake it to make
it is actually
uh spot on there really
i think the more you um
put yourself out there you know join her
it sounds kind of common sense in a way
you know
go to some exercise classes
or whatever floats your boat you know
join a debating society debating club
whatever it might be something that's
going to involve interacting with other
people
practice recalibrate because if you're
if you're a strong introvert you know
you're very kind of sensitive to the
stimulation
actually put yourself out there make
these behavioral changes in your life if
you want to be more extroverted and you
will recalibrate and you'll learn the
skill you know the skills of small talk
that kind of thing you know be a little
bit
uh strategic about it at first you know
uh get up to speed on the latest sports
results so you can have a chat about the
whatever it takes
it's gonna feel forced at the beginning
for sure of course it is
but
practice does make perfect and you'll re
you'll recalibrate there's a brilliant
book um
by jessica pan
something like i can't remember the
title of it but she spent a year livi
she she's a
self-described strong introvert she
challenged herself to
to um spend a year living as an out and
out extrovert she joined an
improvisation club she did stand-up
comedy she did a ton of stuff that's you
know if you're if someone if any of your
listeners are serious about really
wanting to come out of their shell
i think the more they're willing to
take some of those steps it's going to
feel uncomfortable at first no question
but the more
you do it the easier it gets
max dickens was on the show recently
talking about male mental health and and
friendships but he rece before that he
wrote a book about how improv basically
changed his life and he founded a
company called hoopla which is one of
the uk's biggest improv companies and um
he was talking about how important it is
for people you go into improv and he
basically said it's like a trial by fire
of all of the things that you don't want
to do but the point is that failing
in an improv class is applauded so you
get positive reinforcement when you mess
up which makes the price of messing up
significantly less and you're also
watching everybody else mess up and it's
kind of light and i think that there
definitely is i i know in my more
introverted uh times
you create quite a high
um
[Music]
there's a very high sense of pressure
and a felt sense that things matter and
if i say something and it doesn't land
then it's a big deal like if you say
something and it doesn't land it's
really easy to go like well that was a
[ __ ] joke wasn't it and like that's
funny that bit's actually genuinely
funny the fact that your joke was [ __ ]
is is actually interesting and so i
think trying to
you know realize that the stakes are
nowhere near as high as you think they
are especially socially like
i can't remember whose friend it was
someone's grandmother said something
like um we'd care far less about what
other people thought of us if we
realized how rarely they do
and the fact is that most people are
living inside of their own heads like
when was the last time that you can
remember somebody tripping over in the
street or dropping a glass in a
restaurant or whatever you can probably
not remember it and the reason for that
is that
the fact that that exists should give
you unbelievable confidence that you can
mess up on an almost daily basis and
basically no one's going to remember it
yeah i think that's very nice advice a
nice way of putting it i don't know
there's this
funny study i think it was from the 70s
i don't know if you
come across a
i think they call it the spotlight
effect or something where they
they had a student various different
students take turns to in it go into a
group you know like a tutorial situation
and they they got them to wear an
embarrassing t-shirt um i can't remember
an embarrassing t-shirt consistently i
can't remember what it might mean barry
manilow or something like that like like
an uncool t-shirt right very for the
time it was a very it was apparently an
uncle t-shirt i can't remember for sure
who it was and
before the person put it on you know and
went into the tutorial obviously they
asked them what do you think do you
think how many people do you think are
going to notice the t-shirt
and of course people would say well i
think everyone's going to notice it's
going to be excruciating and so on and
then they you can imagine you know you
can guess the researchers then actually
surveyed the other people in the
tutorial group did you notice so-and-so
wearing that embarrassing t-shirt and a
few of them did so it's this mismatch
between
yeah we think the spotlight is on us as
you see you know like you're saying but
it isn't as much as we think it is
christie and jarrod ladies and gentlemen
if people want to keep up to date with
the stuff that you do the articles that
you write all the rest of it where
should they go
oh well i have my own website
christianjarrett.com
i the main kind of social thing media
thing i use is twitter
i'm at psycwriter with an underscore
between the psych and the writer
um
my day job is i'm deputy editor of
psyche magazine
a digital uh online global magazine
where we have all those of brilliant
cool psychology and we have we publish a
new guide every week written by experts
on basically how to live better and that
kind of thing
unreal christian i appreciate you thanks
man
cheers thanks chris what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]
you